For a few years now, the TV show American
Pickers has been running around the United
States digging up little pieces of history,
learning fun stories, then spinning them into
cash.
But who are these representatives of the picking
arts, and what were they like before they
started carting cameras everywhere?
Mike Wolfe
Lead picker Mike Wolfe was born on June 11,
1964 in Bettendorf, Iowa, not far away from
LeClaire, where he'd someday start his flagship
business.
He was picking almost straight out of diapers,
having repaired and flipped a bicycle he found
lying around his neighborhood at the age of
six for five dollars—a princely sum for
a little kid.
Not only that, it was the catalyst to his
dream job, so much so that he has worked on
a book specifically aimed to teach the art
of picking to kids.
Also ingrained in him from childhood was a
long-running interest in bikes.
In the '90s, he owned two biking stores and
competed in races, and his ventures into professional
picking started with quests for old bikes.
However, the allure of picking grew too strong
for Mike and he felt the road calling, so
he bought a van and really got into it.
A few road trips later, somebody suggested
to Wolfe that he should take along a video
camera, and his friend Frank Fritz started
joining in as well.
The pair made a lot of home movies and pitches
over four years before the History Channel
bit the bait and greenlighted the show.
Frank Fritz
Next, we shift the spotlight to Mike Wolfe's
childhood friend since middle school, Frank
Fritz.
He was born on October 11, 1965 in Davenport,
Iowa.
Most of his life was spent helping others
learn to be safe, as Fritz worked as a fire
safety inspector for a quarter century, which
led to his first bits of dabbling in picking
by finding antiques related to firefighting.
Like his friend Wolfe, Fritz also has a passion
for motorcycles, having bought his first Harley-Davidson
as a teenager.
These days, he frequently attends the famed
Sturgis motorcycle rally, and at one point
was president of the Davenport American Bikers
Aimed Toward Education chapter, and even gave
motorcycle safety lessons as well.
He finally got into the picking business full
time when he opened the shop Frank Fritz Finds
in 2002, which is still in Savannah, Illinois.
He and Wolfe kept crossing paths, and eventually
both men started tagging together professionally
and filming their exploits, leading into the
American Pickers show.
Danielle Colby Cushman
A constant presence minding the store in LeClaire
while Wolfe and Fritz are out exploring their
next big item, with the occasional picking
trip thrown in the mix here and there, Danielle
Colby Cushman is also a formidable presence
on the show.
Born on December 3, 1975, Colby was raised
in a family of Jehovah's Witnesses, but her
interests became a lot more varied outside
of the group.
She's also an accomplished burlesque dancer,
to the point that she's toured around the
country under the name Dannie Diesel (a name
she's had since childhood), founded her own
troupe, Burlesque Le Moustache, and opened
her own dance school in Chicago, Dannie Diesel's
Bump n' Grind Academy.
She's also a former roller derby girl, a hobby
that spanned three years until injuries put
an end to it.
Lauren Wray Grisham
One of the managers of the Pickers' Nashville
outpost, Lauren Wray Graham also got into
the picking business early, through her explorations
of old abandoned farmhouses in her hometown
of Athens, Alabama, working a pawn shop with
her dad, and touring antique stores with her
mom.
When it came time to get her college education,
Grisham moved to Tennessee, out near Nashville.
Before she fell in with the Pickers, Grisham
had been serving a stint with Manuel, the
famed rhinestone-loving costume designer who's
made clothing for rock stars, country legends,
Presidents, and even Salvador Dali.
However, she decided she wanted a "big, new
project," and the Pickers just happened to
be expanding their Antique Archaeology business
into Nashville, setting up shop inside a former
car factory.
She joined the team in 2011, and has been
the top representative of the Pickers' southern
branch ever since.
Robbie Wolfe
Mike's brother Robbie Wolfe is occasionally
seen on the show working to help the Pickers,
especially fulfilling since he shares an interest
with Mike in old vehicles, though Robbie prefers
automobiles to motorcycles.
However, when he's not out with his brother
and the rest of the Pickers crew, Robbie is
back in Davenport, where he's been running
his landscaping company RJ Wolfe and Sons,
which he founded in the '90s and is still
running to this day.
They offer an impressively varied list of
services including pool installation, putting
in decks, paving driveways new and old, hooking
up lighting, creating "outdoor living spaces,"
and more.
If you're near Iowa and you like Pickers,
Robbie Wolfe can fix up your yard and buy
some junk from you.
Win win.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!